très bon la pause je voudrais parler de
ce phénomène assez nouveau et magali va
nous en parler de ces candidats de télé
réalité qui vont se faire opérer de
chirurgie esthétique ailleurs il sauf
qu'il ya un cri d'alarmé qui a été qui a
été poussé par un célèbre youtuber qui
s'appelle sam zerah qui dénonce la
manière dont sont utilisées les
candidats de la télé réalité par des
agences de tourisme médical à l'étranger
et maintenant ils ont carrément proposé
d'être rémunéré pour attirer des
candidats pour ce faire deux opérations
à jerez 1 le nez le menton fin ce que
vous voulez le problème c'est que
derrière ça il a reçu une trentaine de
messages disant on est allé c'était
horrible on était opérée à la chaîne
parfois à deux heures du matin donc
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
la chirurgie esthétique penser que la
médecine mais qui doit être fait dans
demain dans un cadre contrôlé et
apparemment c'est un vrai problème
magali c'est un vrai problème a pressé
la chirurgie que ce soit en france ou en
tunisie de toute manière c'est un
problème absolument où on n'est pas
consentant et on n'a pas conscience
vraiment de l'acte qu'on va faire sont
concernés pas conscients des dangers en
jeu voilà ce cadre vous passez
maintenant que ce soit la france ou la
tunisie à des incompétents partout il ya
des gens compétents partout donc faut
bien le dire quand même c'est voilà il
ya des gens dans les cliniques
esthétiques en tunisie qui sont formés
aux états unis et même en france comme
il ya des gens en france qui sont mal
formés
après c'est un choix personnel magali
est très intelligente
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si je ne peux pas laisser passer ce
qu'elle dit parce que magali c'est
intolérable
ce qui se passe là est un danger
sanitaire les aiglons c'est un danger
quand même vous avez des gens vous avez
des gens qui poussent d'autres parce que
ce sont quelque part des modèles
s'éviter danger
met en danger la vie d'autres jeunes qui
veulent faire comme eux donc là le crime
alors pascal quelque part vous avez un
petit pour les moins de 18 ans on est
bien d'accord
ali une très bonne raison vous ne pouvez
pas vous retourner contre le chirurgien
car il est en tunisie alors que si vous
avez un problème si ça se passe mal en
france juste un truc non je vais faire
une pâle ont une portée importante je
parle pas de la tunisie
oui bien sûr je parle du danger dans ce
rejet l'étranger les candidates et les
alter est-européens ailleurs assure même
ça aurait pu l'être en france aux fins
des conséquences parfois dramatiques sur
les résultats physique égale alors se
faire opérer c'est une chose déjà pour
quelle raison mais moi j'ai ramené
quelqu'un qui a participé à l'émission
au bout du monde qui est juste derrière
moi c'est louis marie qui lui a abusé
justement de la chirurgie esthétique
c'est pour faire le nez et les seins le
ventre et les deux chiens les oreilles
c'est un ancien obèse en fait voilà on a
beaucoup maigri ça s'appelle la
conception d'un coup des pectoraux bas
il peut se passer témoigne mais voilà il
est venu là effectivement il en a abusé
aujourd'hui il veut plus en faire juste
juste ainsi aux jeunes au site se
responsabiliser alors évidemment on peut
faire tous des erreurs et c'est aussi
important de venir voir des chirurgiens
en france pourquoi moi j'y réfléchis à
me faire refaire les seins j'ai
carrément pas poitrine je suis allé voir
un chirurgien en france il m'a dit on va
réfléchir francesca rebondirait plaisir
là non mais des fausses prothèse en
plastique et m'a dit si tu es supporter
pendant trois jours je vais réfléchir at
opérer je ne les ai pas supporté et du
coup c'était une bonne idée de ne pas le
faire je veux dire aussi des dans le
temps et qui font pas tout et n'importe
quelle voiture je suis pas refaire les
seins est plate
je vous demande de vous arrêter
gilles une fois plus et rétrograde
arrête de comparer la chirurgie
esthétique à de la boucherie et de très
bons chirurgie esthétique chasse est
très contrôlé et deuxièmement à
l'étranger tu as les chiots jaffres on
sait qu'ils vont opérer l'étranger moi
je me suis fait opérer une fois ni
chaussettes éthique c'est vous parce que
il ment perez était le lundi et jeudi on
peut se voir la semaine prochaine je
peux pas être la semaine prochaine je
quand tu n'hésites pour opérer la même
chose que vous il m'avoue après ces mots
qui fusent européenne en tunisie
s'aventurer coûté trois fois ma chère à
puisse nous aurons faire le tapis c'est
pas de balance quand on se voit avec
cyril à sa base tous brutale avec ben
alors alors vous atteignez où
l'intelligence et de jeux d'été
si je voulais témoigner vous aimeriez au
fait où c'est dommage non mais moi je
voulais dire que pourquoi on va faire ou
pourquoi pas les voir parce que ces low
cost c'est juste cette barre et voilà je
suis bon